this morning the four nations of the
united kingdom
issued a joint statement it said
we are seeing the start of a second wave
looking at today's data you can see why
the national r
number is now well above one and if we
look at the regional numbers
we're no longer seeing growth confined
to one area
this outbreak all these are above one
this outbreak
the government says is now widespread
today we also got the office for
national statistics survey which is a
really reliable measure of the outbreak
because it tests around 10 000
households week after week
last week it estimated 6 000 new
infections a day
this week it's 9600
up two-thirds in about a week
so who's actually being hit by covid
this chart of uk hospitalizations by age
since august tells us
and it has a really interesting feature
so we know that older people
especially men are very hard hit but
instead of looking like an upside down
pyramid
this chart now looks like a tornado
because it has this
bulge at the side young women between
the ages of 25
and 29 are increasingly likely
to be hospitalized with covid and one
sage member told
us that was probably because of the
opening up
of retail hospitality so the good news
is there's not much light blue here very
few of these young women are dying
the worry is that they might spread it
to more vulnerable people
which is why self-isolation is so
important
and on that topic the news is not good
this study asked 32 000 people
whether they would self-isolate if they
had symptoms
this is what they said they'd do and
this
is what they actually did less than 20
percent of people
actually self-isolated and the people
less likely to comply were young male
had children and crucially were poorer
on
average so new payments during
self-isolation
might change that but with cases rising
fast
the fear is this action might be too
little
too late